good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is don't be afraid of
losses over to you Robert Kiyosaki well
most successful entrepreneurs have gone
bust you know Henry Ford an old-time
entrepreneur he went bust five times
okay look look at Steve Jobs yet his own
board fired him yep you know Bill Gates
was taken before the Supreme Court for
monopolistic practices right even my
friend Donald Trump went down a billion
dollars yeah I only went down a million
so the average person is so afraid of
those losses they never get ahead
because at school they teach you if you
make a mistake or if you fail you're a
failure but that's not real life a baby
alarms to walk by standing up and
falling down standing up and falling
down and our school system punishes you
for making mistakes that's why my poor
debt an academic was so unsuccessful it
was terrified of making mistakes most
people are so afraid to lose that they
don't even try we have these big dreams
big ambitions big products to want to
work on and here's the mind twist this
is this is why it's so hard it's so fun
to think about where we can go it's so
fun to think about my channel and a
million subscribers it's so fun to think
about you on that beach or you on in
that car you have in that big business
you have in that big impact it's so it's
so amazing in our heads of that life
that we want to live but doing the work
actually is hard and especially at the
beginning when you create your first
thing it's going to suck and you're
afraid of how people are going to react
to it the judgments from your friends
from your parents and the people around
you you look at it say that's not very
good and as soon as you start making
that and you get the negativity in the
criticism also from yourself knowing
that what you made
sock it starts to eat away at that dream
you start to think that big dream is not
possible anymore and so what ends up
happening to so many people is that just
stop the jizz don't do anymore they
don't take any more action because they
can stay in their head and just imagine
about the one day this thing is going to
happen because it's it sets off the
endorphins it makes you happy but doing
the work is painful and stressful and
negative and again every time you do it
it cracks away at you actually thinking
that big dream is possible if you don't
do any work you can just stay in your
head and stay happy but what's going to
happen it's kind of like some of those
movies where you know what's going to
happen are those puzzles where you know
what the answer is you don't want to do
the puzzle anymore the excitement is
just going to figuring out the problem
and so it's really exciting to figure
out a problem I know how to solve this
problem here's what Google should do
here's what McDonald's should do here's
what coca-cola should do I know how to
solve their business problem it's really
fun thinking through the exercise of
cells in the problem but actually doing
the work sucks and so people don't do
the work they just dip in their head you
need to learn to stop that you need to
learn to be patient need to learn to do
the work you need to learn to actually
go out and accomplish the big thing that
you want to accomplish the big thing
that you say is so important to you to
get it out of your head and start taking
the action to make it happen because we
all have these dreams everybody has a
dream everybody wants more out of life
ever you want to have a greater
contribution but most of us are not
mapping our actions to go achieving
those dreams you're not taking the daily
consistent action to make it happen and
so you need to every single day take
some kind of action move closer to your
goal expect the suck expect to be
criticized by your yourself your own
hatred of your own work as well as the
people around you that's normal that's
to be expected anticipate that because
if you go and think in big dream and
then your first thing sucks and you get
depressed and you quit that's not going
to help expect the suck I expect the
next one to suck a little bit less like
so it's like a little bit less and
taking daily consistent action so you
can get out of your head and start
actually accomplishing things so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what was the first thing you did to take
that big dream that you had and actually
take some action on it and implement it
it was the first action item that
you took leaving the comments below
really refine it I also want to give a
quick chatter - Eric Eric thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word
I really really appreciate this
apartment and I hope you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I will see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
failure is part of life I mean the
difference for me though is I look a
failure as a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm going to
fail but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability to influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that mess me up
but I show people that didn't let them
stop me and you only to stop you and I
think I think that's really a secret
matter and it's everything you touch was
successful well I want to relate to
people's Miley relate and also be total
bullsh everyone knows both and also
you'd be bored silly I mean think about
it if you just said I want this to
happen I want this to happen you know
people don't value it they don't fight
for you know it's like you see kids
sometimes in it you know your parents
will say you're not going to value this
if you don't work for it and you're
keeping on value just give it to me
but it's true you know about things
we've worked the hardest for we value
the most so I think you know the purpose
of the goal is not getting it anyway the
purpose of goal you know is what who you
become who you become is going to make
you happier going to make you sad so I'm
not looking for an effortless approach
recession there's no such thing you
should seek failures see if you're
playing it safe you're not going to win
if you're playing it safe like that all
say you know you were telling your
little girl better to be safe than sorry
well that's a bunch of crap it's not
better be safe than sorry it's by trying
things that you figure out how far you
can go you got to get outside the box
like it's reported Edison tried 3000
ways before he built the incandescent
light he said he didn't deal 3,000 times
he said there was 3,000 different steps
to building a light bulb well there's
different steps to get to where you're
going and I really do treat winning and
losing exactly the same I do not let it
upset me do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful well it's
part of why I enjoy it
yeah I think it is because I'll try
anything like if if I'm into an idea the
idea of losing never enters my mind see
I have worked with Giants I had the good
fortune of working with Sir Edmund
Hillary he was the first man to stand on
top of the world and I worked with him
on three different occasions and the
only difference in ed Hillary and Bob
Proctor is in his his size now he's gone
now but he was a big man he shook hands
with me his hand wrapper right around
mine I felt like Oh dwarf you know and
and talked into him like it never
entered his mind he wouldn't get to the
top of the mountain but he failed in
1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to live
talk to the mum know people had died for
centuries trying to do that he said I
knew if I could see it in here I can
hold it out here still a man wrote that
in the book you can see it in your head
you can hold it in your hand and that's
right and if you're not prepared to lose
you're never gonna win because you're
always playing it safe and there's no
there's no reward in that yeah I think
failure is the highway to success and I
know that sounds like a platitude but
Society or people teach us right they
say oh if you fail and feel
uncomfortable you've done something
wrong and what I try to do in all of my
books and my presentations and my tweets
and is them you cannot get to the
mountaintop without taking a few
missteps and so a business that wants to
win you have to out fail your
competition and as human beings you know
failure is not a bad thing you know ask
yourself what's the opportunity from the
failure and get in the game because when
you get to the last hour of your last
day it will not be the failures you
regret it will be all the risks you
didn't pay